في ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
السلطاتو دوناتس كالمواليه لموسكو ان
القوات الروسيه تسيطر على نحو نصف مدينه
بخموت من جانب اقلت القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه ان جنودها يدافعون عن بخموت
وانهم لم يغادرها ونشرت القوه الاوكرانيه
صورا قالت انها للعمليات في باخموت واكدت
ان جنودها مازالوا في المدينه التي وصفتها
بالصامده دوريها قله الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تواصل محاولاتها
لاقتحام بخموت رغم الخسائر الكبيره
حسن الشوبكي ومن موسكو مراسله الجزيره
رانيا الدريدي لنبدا معك حسن الشوبكي ان
كان هناك اي حديث في كييف او تعليق بشان
نقل عن القوات المواليه لروسيا في دنيتك
ان نصف مدينه
اصبحت تحت السيطره الروسيه
حتى اللحظه حسن لا يوجد رد على هذا الحديث
الروسي الاخير الذي جاء في الساعه الاخيره
لكن التاكيدات تصل تباعا من ان المعارك
ضاريه ومستمره في
ان الحصار الذي يتحدث عنه الروس
يقابله الاوكرانيون بالقول بان هنالك جبهه
مفتوحه باتجاه
المجال الشمالي الغربي من مدينه باقمت
ولذلك فان الامدادات والمؤن وحتى نقل
الجرحى تتم من خلال هذا المجال
بالتاكيد ان هنالك ثلاثه محاور محاصره لكن
العمليه مستمره في في باك موت وهنالك
اصرار من القياده السياسيه هنا في كييف
كما حدث في الاجتماع الذي حدث بالامس
واستمر لساعه وقال فيه الرئيس الاوكراني
انه سال بشكل واضح
كلا من القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
وكذلك قائد القوات الشرقيه وهو ايضا قائد
للقوات البريه الاوكرانيه
سالهم هل الخيار التراجع هو المطروح ام
تعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه هناك وكانت
الاجابه بان لا تراجع من باخمت وان ايضا
التعزيز هو الذي سيتم مطالبه في الاجتماع
بتقديم قوات اضافيه تساند القوات الموجوده
في باقي مت اذن التاكيدات
الاوكرانيه تشير الى ذلك وتساندها ايضا
تاكيدات غربيه يعني عندما قال بالمتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ند برايس ان
المعارك في باخ متستنزف القوات الروسيه
وانها لا تستطيع ان تتقدم اكثر وجاء ايضا
تقرير للمخابرات البريطانيه واكد ذات
الامر بالقول ان القوات الروسيه تخسر بشكل
كبير وان الدفاعات
ليس هذا فحسب بقى